c'est le dossier qui a tout bousculé au
congrès la destitution a pris énormément
de place exacerbant davantage des
divisions profondes et aux nas pour les
démocrates le président a abusé de ses
pouvoirs en demandant à l'ukraine
d'enquêter sur un adversaire politique
il accuse également d'entrer au travail
du congrès ce n'est pas assez pour le
destituer répondent les républicains qui
évoque les chefs d'accusation les plus
faibles de l'histoire
le compte à rebours est commencé
tout indique que cette semaine la
chambre accusera formellement le
président qui a moins de revirements
pourrait être acquitté après un procès
au sénat et pendant qu'ici le débat se
poursuit à l'extérieur du capitole
démocrates et républicains continuent
d'évaluer l'impact corps à cette
procédure de destitution sur l'électorat
américain et wana mauvais il faut passer
rapidement à autre chose conseil cette
stratège démocrate de longue date
elle croit que compte tenu des gestes
reprochés adam trompe son parti devait
intervenir
c lin d'oeil constate que la grande
majorité de la base démocrate est
favorable à la destitution
mais que le choix de la sphère
ukrainienne pour agir soulève certaines
questions
cet ancien conseiller républicain au
sénat constatent néanmoins des
différences dans le camp du président
avec le taux de chômage le plus faible
en 50 ans
plusieurs estiment que dans mon choc
devrait vanter ses succès économiques
mais parler de destitution pour
galvaniser ses partisans est plus fort
que lui
dans le camp démocrate également
plusieurs souhaite que la campagne
électorale ne porte pas sur cette saga
de la destitution
les candidats à l'investiture du parti
l'ont bien démontré
si tu utilises la procédure de
destitution pour attaquer la crédibilité
de donald trump les candidats n'en font
pas un thème central de leurs débats
les américains sont divisés comme
rarement auparavant
si la destitution mobilise la base
électorale dans les deux camps l'impact
pourrait être limité auprès des
électeurs indépendants ou modéré
l'an prochain ce sont eux qui pourrait
faire pencher la balance ici rafa
bouvier auclair radio-canada washington